[Music]
hello my name is Hannah Dickinson and
this is cheers to you where I'm taking
off my first round of the weekend by
choosing all the people and stories that
encourage me to drink cheers to you
Japanese princess for renouncing your
royal status to marry a commoner but
upholding the world tradition of women
dating down Cheers see you 50 cent for
buying 200 tickets to jor-el's concert
so the front row will be empty or cheers
to you general for finally selling 200
tickets really so cheers to you jenna
jameson for breastfeeding your daughter
for 18 months that's honestly nothing
compared to the 18 years you breastfed
your co-stars cheers to Don McLean for
dating a woman 49 years younger than you
I can't imagine anything worse than
having sex with a 74 year old except pay
my own rent
does anyone old watch Comedy Central
speaking of old men cheers to you Ben
and Jerry's for putting on a flavor
protesting Trump called pecan resist now
that two more old white guys are
throwing their nuts around everything's
fixed cheers to you Tommy Lauren for
defending Megyn Kelly's heinous
blackface comments
but who will defend your heinous bangs
it's that political its aesthetic
they're terrible
you went from a ten that's like a six
and you don't believe in feminism so I
can say that cheers to you lime for
recalling your electric scooters and
fear they'll catch fire make sense
because every time I ride one it's black
be sure to check out the rest of our
show Monday through Thursday every damn
day Cheers
[Music]